what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 25th of october the
joint is brought to you by blue shoe oh
[__]
blue chew is here to make your dick all
that it could be let me tell you
something blue chew is tremendous
it's taste good
it takes about 25 minutes to get the
[__] party started
blue chew is an online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and salis at a fraction of the
cost it's tremendous you could take one
anytime
day or night
your dick is hard but joey i'm 28 i'm
not an old [__] like you my dick is
already hard well listen how hard can it
[__] be it can't be that harder you
want her to [__] call you tomorrow
and go my [__] doesn't stop smoking
why because you showed up with blue chew
dick
the process is simple you sign up at
bluetooth.com you talk to one of the
licensed medical providers once you're
approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
of this blue chew is it's all online
nobody knows dick no doctor's office no
pharmacy no judging you go to [__]
cvs she's not going to brow beat you to
[__] death when she's looking at you
it ships right to your door in a
discreet little package not even the
mailman knows dick bluetooth tablets are
made in the usa usa usa usa there's
nothing stronger than the usa wants and
a big strong dick and blue chew will
give you that right now
do me a favor
go to bluechew.com
for help
if you could use some a little benefit
and a little extra confidence to perform
forget about it i'm over here building
[__] marines but it starts with a
blue chew [__] and they got a special
deal for you
try blue chew for free joey what the
[__] don't [__] with my emotions it's
monday for free with promo code joey
j-o-e-y just pay a fin five dollars for
shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code joey to receive
your first month for free and as always
i want to thank blue chew for sponsoring
the joint the joint is also brought to
you by one of my all-time [__]
favorites
on it
listen they're not [__] around on it
is not [__] around this new
black label
alpha brain i'm telling you you guys are
looking at me
it's between the alpha brain the therapy
the lifting weights the sleeping it all
finally came together i'm a lot fluent
i'm having a great time and
i'm [__] back it feels like i'm
[__] like i gotta pull myself back
that's the [__] alpha brain if you're
feeling a little lost lately
you know you're having a hard time
spitting up [__] words like i did for
a year give the alpha brain a shot
listen if it doesn't work for you
there's 100 money back guarantee and
they don't want the product back that's
how much they believe in their product
alpha brain comes in tablets it comes in
a powder it comes in a prepared juice
already plus you know me i'm a shroom
tech fan another thing that's really
helped me during this uh period has been
the new mood at night tremendous
if you're [__] going through what i'm
going through right now you take two of
them at night you sleep nappy nunu but
it's all about alpha brain it's all
about on it i want you to go to
honor.com right now
look at the great selection of
supplements i can't help you with the
kettlebells or the club bats but alpha
brain it's monday you want to start
november off slinging dick with blue
chew and firing on all cylinders with
alpha brain go to honor.com right now
preston joey joint get 10 off on it
delivered right to your house and
remember they're having their [__]
sale their cyber sale black friday sale
in november i'll keep you guys posted
but jump on the black label alpha brain
right now to get everything going go to
honor.com press in joey your joint and
get 10 percent off
delivered right to your [__] house
let's get this party started today
it's monday morning we gotta [__]
sling some dick we're taking prisoners
we're like [__] vietnam you
understand me i love you [__]
let's get this party started
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday october the 25th
six days away
from [__] spookyville
and the whole thing it was a great
[__] weekend i had a great week
thank you for being here thank you for
checking in let's open up the week with
[__] ice cream shop
has got the blunts in stock they went in
partnership with packwoods laughing gas
is now in a blunt and let me tell you
something i hope you love your eyes
because i had to actually hold an eye
while i was smoking this [__]
your eye is gonna fly the [__] out
i want to thank [__] uh
pipe freeze for sending us a bung
freezepipe.com for sending us a new pipe
and a bot and a little [__] smoker
for my man mike klein there
so now he's at home doing i love when i
give mike weed like i don't even have to
[__] ask him if the weed is good i
just wait a night and look at his
artwork when i see that a picture of a
devil [__] a monkey i'm like that
weed is good you know what i'm saying
i'll watch some of the rogan posters and
[__] and i go this weed is [__] hold
me up
kind of out there
yeah they're out there because i'm
giving them the weed of death there's
one day i woke up he wrote three songs
he composed the [__] album overnight
i woke up at eight in the mornings i
wrote an album and performed it last
night what the [__] mike that i'm like i
gave him that weed he gets like lee
remember when lee used to smoke he used
to come up with business benches i got a
new idea for floatable donuts you know
[__] like that there was always
something every time you gave them good
weed they go home and they come back
with a [__] uh
a guitar you know they come home with
something they come back with some i
thought you needed a guitar that's
[__] tremendous
so yeah it's uh it's always great to
smoke some good reefer on the [__]
weekend
dog it was a great i i posted a picture
the other day
since i have moved here
people have been telling me about this
restaurant el nido
joe you got to go to home need him joe
you got to go to home
it's close to my house
when i go to the gym i have to drive by
that
and i see the they have like little uh
boots outside that you could sit with
your girlfriend
just to loan a booth if you want they
could they close the curtains for you i
love that [__] when i first got into
comedy i used to do comedy at a place
called the broker great [__]
restaurant i loved it till this day i'm
very loyal to them they won't let me
back in the place to do comedy but
you know some people have short memories
you know saying
no everybody says everybody says they're
a christian but they don't practice what
they preach you know what i'm saying
so they had four restaurants they had
like the broker in boulder
they had the broker and like aurora
every one of them had a different name
but
they had the broker in denver and it was
called the women's bank
and you're like the woman's bank ah
until you went down there for starters
the broker when you sit down they'd open
up with a bat with a [__] not a cup
not a not a thing not like a soup bowl
i wish i was exaggerating to you they'd
open up with a manhole cover filled with
shrimp
katrina shrimp you know the ones i'm
talking about the ones you dip in soy
sauce not soy sauce cocktail sauce if
you eat 20 of those you're gonna [__]
blood because they don't clean them
they're just the little geeky ones but
you know what when you're 31 and broke
you will eat those [__] like
that filet mignon you know you throw
them up in the air like [__] just
lick them out of the air i would go to
the broker just for the [__] shrimp
and they would bring you a bowl but the
thing about the ladies bank was the
woman's bank
i take a date with me
come on dog when you're young and you're
doing a couple [__] bumparoos you
close the curtains you eat a monkey
and then breakfast is served you know
what i'm saying
boom the way that comes my answer might
come in absolutely you pull up a little
pantyhose
and you sit there and eat your [__]
shrimp you eat 20 shrimp you got a heart
on and you close the curtain again and
give another stab and doggy style nobody
knows nothing who gives about the flower
and her [__] it's a little [__] up you
swooshed it you know what i'm saying you
smooshed it [__] it
but i like that [__] when you could
close the curtain and stuff not that i
would do anything perverted down there
but i'm saying that so it seemed
interesting to me you know i'm like to
have curtains then i joined the pool and
at the pool
there were these little [__] old
dudes
that were retired but there was this one
dude a jewish dude
sweetheart phil
he would always talk to me about
restaurants this guy would spit out
restaurants from boston iowa
because he traveled for a living so he
that was his thing was hunting down
restaurants you know this guy could tell
you like i asked him about a restaurant
he's like
what do you think about the fountain
when somebody tells you
what you think about the fountain
they looked at all the details like they
like that [__] you know there's people
who live for that [__]
and he was telling me that that
restaurant is in the top five
restaurants in jersey he goes i did the
math he goes this is what i do this
guy's retired he goes out to dinner five
nights a [__] week all over the place
plus my man dave baton db orthopedics
i'm gonna give him a shout out he helped
me with my knee he's trying to help me
with my right and left knee now to get
the arthritis out of there
db orthopedics that [__] knows
every slice of pizza
every meatball from here to [__]
delaware it's unbelievable and he was
telling me like since the beginning even
when we go out to different dinners he
would go dog i'm going to take you
telling neato one day i'm going to take
your telnet but then i heard mixed
reviews people were like it's really
good but it's not my type of italian
food
and i get it and then people are saying
well they don't give you big servings
and i get it it's fine dining what are
you a [__] gorilla go to burger king
if you want to eat all you want to eat
yeah yeah you got to have some [__]
cadence in your [__] life what are
you [__]
so i finally me and my wife you know we
try to do a date night once a month i
mean with the kid we we're out all the
time eating with the kids and [__] you
know medium range restaurants
wings pizzas i get the salads
[__] like that but you know you got to
take them to a carpet joint from time to
time you know what i'm saying you got to
take them through a rug joint you know
fine dining [__] some guy playing a
violin not that they're playing a violin
el nido they don't need to play a violin
they don't need no [__] gimmicks or
nothing so [__] thursday night me and
my wife went down there
holy [__] that's all i could say holy
[__] first off it's all organic the
owner
his name is joe he's a 78 year old joe
rogan
it's like if joe rogan was 78 years old
when they bring you every dish they
explain the history
to you of that dish and what region of
italy it came from now you guys know me
a long time you ever see those waiters
they bring you a glass of wine and you
have to taste it then they stand there
it's like
yeah just pour the [__] glass well
you know i'm one of those [__]
gorillas too you know what i'm saying
but
uh
it was just sharp like from the minute
you walk in there
we sat down [__]
you would never hear this word out of me
the ambiance is tremendous when he came
over he confirmed it you know i have a
problem hearing that's why i have those
hearing aids
i have a problem when i go to a
restaurant when two people when i'm
talking to mike let's say at a
restaurant i don't really hear mike
i hear the dishwasher in the back
slamming i can hear the cooks talking
because my hearing is [__] off so
when i go to a restaurant nine out of
ten times
the food better be good because if not
it's an uncomfortable situation for me
i'm unfunked and comfortable with that
like i i can't hear so when you're
talking to me not this place and when
joe the owner came home we were talking
he explained to me that he installed
something in the ceiling
so all the sound gets just
way ahead of the [__] curve
way ahead of the curve all their
ingredients are 85 percent imported
i mean you got to taste this [__] he
grows all his vegetables
so when you put a vegetable like
whatever you think a green bean tastes
like when you taste it in there it's
what it should taste like the [__]
chicken in there
it it just breaks off it's it's those
chickens that have not been kicked you
know those chickens that people were
nice to them like they pet them and
played like uh flute music too like jet
girl tall goes over there when they're
in their cages and he plays a little
soft loop music and he throws [__]
rose water at him these are the chickens
they [__] like they give you like as
you're killing them you're crying
because you feel bad they know how to
say the abcs they're that type of
[__] chickens the chicken melts it's
like chicken from 30 years ago like
before the steroids and everybody [__]
up chicken and started putting [__] and
chicken and now it has that weird taste
to it but you eat it like a [__]
animal because there's nothing better
than fried chicken
you don't give a [__] when you're eating
fried chicken but the chick everybody i
talked to said when i go to el nido what
should i eat and i said eat the chicken
and i'm like it's [__] fine dining
who eats the chicken well i went
thursday night
friday night
we had a kids party
that was really cool they showed a movie
outside it was great
saturday i took out a kickbox and did
what i had to do
saturday night a buddy of mine from
north bergen called me old school
40 years ago the whole [__] deal he
called me in the afternoon said he
hadn't been out in two weeks i said to
him i don't know what to tell you i'm
not [__] i don't own studio 54
anymore you know what i'm saying
okay
yeah i don't know what to tell you i
can't do nothing for you if you don't
get out you got to get the [__] out
i had a birthday uh party to go to last
night with the kids and [__]
so i said to him listen if you want to
come down here they're family these
people you come over with me or
come on down
it's a 45 minute drive for you clear
your head and you've been in the house
all [__] week
clear your coconut and we'll go get a
bite to eat or something something small
i had already eaten lunch had already a
protein shake when he called i wasn't
really that hungry but
i [__] said [__] it we'll uh figure
something out sure enough he showed up
around seven o'clock
and uh we called the restaurant that he
wanted to try and the restaurant was
sold out
he goes what type of [__] guy are you
i don't know don't you have any
connections to get meals i'm a dog i
don't know anybody
so i said but we weren't telling needle
the other night and the owner joe gave
me a card and he said to call him that
he's always got a spare table
i go even if we have to sit outside do
you want to go don't need him he goes
yeah i'll try it we went and we had a
[__] blast last night we were there
for two hours
no i had a little taste of red wine just
the perfect [__] amount to give me a
headache i didn't get sick
i had some spaghetti i ate light last
night a little spaghetti half a a
serving and i had a piece of fish
zero [__] points and [__]
and uh we laughed our asses off i took
some pictures of some people
i laughed with some people and we were
home by nine [__] 30. you know he
goes to sleep [__] early
so i came home and i watched [__]
atlanta beat the [__] out of the dodgers
what a shame that was last night the
[__] dodgers
spent all this money on a [__]
baseball team
you know it's like i go to say to you
guys you can get the most expensive
coaches in the world
but if you ain't got no [__] uh you
know whatever nah you only tell what
happened with them i think
they won a lot of games they played a
lot of [__] games and they were just
beat up they were just beat up it's it's
the season starts in [__] february
april
you know they're throwing pitches and
catches it's a long [__] season and
with baseball to win a world series you
all have to come together in october
it's a big it's like a 50 50 shot you go
out you get all these [__] players
you get out you get all these pictures
and come october september everybody's
[__] hurt it's a long season so
that's why you they make those
mid-season trades before the all-star
game you bench these people you let them
get out of their [__] rotation a
little bit and then you start them again
and hopefully they're on fire you know
when you have a team of nine people you
eliminate the pitcher that's eight
people eight bats are coming up i need
three of them to be [__] hot i don't
care which three
i just need three bats to be hot that's
how the yankees want it for years that's
how they were playing great ball
you come together in october like
when i was doing comedy
stand up all the time towards the end my
pieces were really coming together it
takes a while
but you either you either fall apart in
october you're tired your injuries
little nagging injuries you pulled the
muscle in your shoulder i think that
bullpen if you watch the game on
saturday night
what was shocking to me was that
the dodgers pretty much put in their
best [__] reliever that big [__]
african-american dude that throws
[__] heat in the top of the eighth
inning and he threw two pitches and a
[__] hit him with a double
like when you put your best reliever on
there and somebody blast the [__]
double off you in the eighth inning and
he came in fresh and this guy's been
playing since the first inning
they lost that you could see it
if you watch the game saturday night
once he threw that [__] pitch and the
dude
he just all the oxygen went out of him
it was over the game was over the series
was over i'm not mad at anybody they
played a [__] great game
uh atlantic
nobody [__] saw him coming
and that's what the world series is
about
is about you get one popular team in
there and one team that nobody saw
coming we call it what you want a
cinderella and that's what makes it
beautiful if it was the houston astros
against
the yankees
who gives a [__] this is an interesting
world series so i don't know what you're
doing for the world series if you want
to click on draftkings right now
they have uh
they have a link that you could just bet
the series
if you just don't want to bet the set
five games or whatever
you could just click on the link bet
[__] atlanta braves or the houston
astros
and knock yourself the [__] out i'm
gonna watch the games i'm excited now we
got a little [__]
we got a little little [__] football
we got a little [__] world series
ball we got a little nba ball we got it
all guys things are [__] happening
and they're moving [__] quickly what
i wanted to talk to you guys about today
the thing that
everybody's talking about here
that uh what the [__] is this why do i
always [__] myself up
does anybody [__] know why i [__]
myself up
it doesn't
that laughing gas [__] me up this
weekend plus i've been [__] doing
those uh
they sent me some tinctures
you know i got to switch up the [__]
like i was doing abx's to go to sleep
i switched it up because your body gets
[__] tolerant of it i switched it up
from abx
i did the right thing i went from abx
and i switched it up to a tincture which
let's say if i want to go to bed at 11
30 i got to drop these tinctures at nine
o'clock it takes a while for them to hit
you it's like a fat dude that's old
throwing a punch at you it's going to
take like eight years for it to land and
[__] because he's fat he's breathing
heavy but once it [__] lands on you
but boom it's all over
but the [__] shot
it's crazy how
i'm watching baseball i'm doing things
i haven't done in 30 years
and i'm doing things i never did at all
like this has just been
[__] a great time for me just to take
this breather guys you don't know
you have no [__] idea what i've gone
through the last 30 [__] years
working
being on sets
podcasting dealing with ages you know
what man
it's been nice to take a breather it's
been nice to find the real joey diaz
it's been nice to unwind it's been nice
to just
when your life i'm
i miss so many things in my [__] life
i missed them because i had a mission
and that's okay i could deal with that
then
but i can't deal with it now i got one
foot in the grave one a banana peel i
don't know when this is gonna [__]
end but
i'm doing things i'm smelling things
i'm seeing things that i have not seen
in 30 years my life you know this makes
me realize how much of a commitment
i had towards stand-up comedy and to
become a great stand-up comic it takes a
lot of commitment it takes a lot of your
hours
it takes a lot of time and it's kind of
nice to unwind
to see where the [__] you are but i'll
tell you what it's also kind of
refreshing to know
that even as as now as i'm writing a
couple jokes here and there i'm writing
from a new perspective it's not about a
stinky muffler anymore you know i had to
grow my comedy had to grow
so i had to get that that vocabulary out
of my [__] game i don't know if you
guys
understand where the [__] i'm going with
this but
that's what needed to be done when i
found myself going back to
uncle vinnie's like last january even
though i had taken an eight month break
i had no material so i was going back to
the not doing old material but i was
talking about old [__]
of me living in california that was part
of me wanted to take a break also i
wanted to reprogram my [__] head i
wanted to
you know why rewire my brain
i was
intelligent enough to take a look and go
i got to back off a little bit i got a
[__] papa's got to show up with a brand
new band do you know what i'm saying you
just can't [__] show up and be doing
the same thing with a different three
people you gotta show up with something
you gotta so it's been great i i've
gotten a chance to [__] uh
step back
smell the roses you know like what the
[__] is going on in the words of jim
morrison take a look around say which
way the wind blow we're the little girl
and a hollywood bungalow you know what
i'm saying you gotta [__] you know so
i didn't want to come off the [__]
ship and just run out there
getting led by my nose i wanted to take
my time see what the [__] was going on
and i appreciate that you guys
appreciate that that i didn't even know
what the [__] was happening and now
i feel so much better about it and part
of it listen guys
and i was when mike came in today i was
talking to a friend of mine who called
me he's going through a hard part right
now
and he said to me you know is it
do you think the therapy helped you and
i go no
there was a couple of events and a
couple things that had to happen for me
to get there but everything combined
you know when you go to jujitsu right
let's just take jujitsu for example i'll
take stand-up comedy when you take
jiu-jitsu to example for example it's
not just going to class
it's not just going to class
you got to eat good
you got to drink water
you got to [__] sleep good
you got to [__] lift weights
you gotta run a little bit for cardio
you gotta do all these different things
to make who the [__] you are with me
it's acupuncture jiu-jitsu lifting
weights spending time with my family
spending time with my friends
sleeping
smoking good reefer
all these things contribute you know my
reef intake has been
uh
down i mean [__] way down one joint a
day way down friday already came down i
got to tell you something about a round
of applause
i smoked before two o'clock
me and ari smoked one of those [__]
uh uh whatever
and uh one of the laughing gas blunts
from packwood
and we went to the szechuan [__]
place we had some
chicken
what's that thing he likes general tao's
chicken extra spicy i could see his
yarmulke fly right the [__] off
we had uh some nice rice i had some nice
[__] uh
i had the chicken and shrimp with string
beans delicious no point three points
for the sauce yeah
and six for the rice yeah
it's a little bit of rice we had a
little egg drop soup ari had some
[__] egg rolls
with [__] tons of mustard on it that
[__] loves his food spicy
and then we came up here we sat around
we [__] played with his dog my
daughter played with his dog it was a
very nice little afternoon we just sat
got a little vitamin d and chit-chatted
that's it very therapeutic as they say
you know what i'm saying
just a little something to get the party
started but i don't want you guys to
think that it was everything
it was everything when i was going
through my little [__] spell there
there was every time mike was coming up
i felt like calling mike and going mike
i can't do this i can't handle doing i
still remember telling mike mike i'm
gonna go on medication
i need your help watch me from time to
time if you see me going off the deep
end
turn off the [__] camera and stop the
butt nothing we've been fine but i told
them i made them aware of what i was
going on and
it was so [__] weird where my head
was at i mean between my anxiety i was
telling arya a little touch of
depression like thank god i'm the type
of dude that the first thing i do when i
wake up is wash my [__] depression does
not like showers they want you to be
dirty and greasy and that's what i do as
soon as i get up in the morning you take
that cup of coffee you take a shower and
you force yourself to go out and thank
god i would go to the gym and it was
[__] uncomfortable as [__] with the
anxiety but i didn't give a [__] i knew
that the end result would be great i
have been feeling a lot [__] better
lately i mean
200 [__] percent better my sense of
humor's back
i feel
lighter on my feet i feel [__]
stronger and i thank everybody who
supported me along the way i thank my
wife i thank michael you know i came
clean with all my friends and told them
what i was going through that i needed
that you know i watched triggers you
know anything that would set me off i
learned how to get in my car and i
learned listen
when you're trying to get back on your
feet or you're trying to get back
mentally
you have to take everything in you know
i had to start over again i gave the
edibles a breather i started sleeping
again i gave the reefer breathing just
to see what would work
you know what what works for me you know
what smoking dope all day doesn't work
for me but smoking a joint at night
never killed nobody
never killed nobody you understand me a
little salute about 10 o'clock watch tv
till midnight you're [__] fine but
i rolled it all together with better
help i don't know if you guys know this
your joint is sponsored by better help
online therapy
the best way to think about therapies
like this all right we all get all
changes to our cause to prevent bigger
issues down the road
therapy is the same thing for you but
it's for your [__] brain going to
therapy is routine maintenance for your
mental and emotional wellness prevent
bigger issues down the road that's what
i did
so that's how it's helped me
betterhelp.com my girl dana
we hook up once a week 8 45 a.m on
mondays i started off on a monday
so i get all the [__] out from the
weekend so already today i've talked to
[__] dana she's on she's probably
dancing some [__] party right now i
did my little chit chat i got whatever
and i talked about hangs and hangs in
the fences that's it so if you got a
[__] problem right now and you need
some help you need to talk to somebody
other than your friends better help is
customized online therapy they offer
video phone and even chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
have to see anyone on camera if you
don't want it it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can start
communicating with your therapist in 48
hours why invest in anything else when
you can invest in your [__] self
just for you joint family listeners i'm
going to give you 10 percent off your
first month
at betterhelp.com
diaz d i a z
that's betterhelp.com
diaz i'm gonna give you ten percent off
your first month whether you do two
sessions or four sessions i don't care
what you do take control of your life
and get the help you deserve with better
help let's drop that on you just so you
know where i'm coming from today i want
to talk to you guys about something that
i know that you've all read about
the last couple days i'm going to break
it down for you and tell you the truth
about it
i don't give a [__] about who gets mad
or who doesn't get mad
last week something happened that [__]
everybody up with alec baldwin shooting
the
the a.d on the set in santa fe new
mexico
you know man and everybody's pointing
fingers alex baldwin and [__] because
you know alec baldwin has created this
aura around him
well he's always got to say creepy [__]
[__] creepy so people
want to put them under the jail listen
alec baldwin is a [__] creepy guy and
his ego got control of him
and it's [__] up but now i want you
know i went to california six months ago
i had to see the dentist
i had to see my heart doctor and i had
to go see the weed people
and while i was when i finished and i
was waiting to get back on the plane
i called my man dean delray and i asked
dean if you wanted to go eat and dean
came
we went we got some mexican food we got
some potato tacos
he brought his cute little dog
and we just [__]
we just bullshitted about life and what
was going on and how he was feeling i
was still [__] up i was going through
my [__]
we had a great chat and we walked
outside and while we were outside
just sitting on burbank boulevard in
front of the hotel
dean goes hey man before i leave can we
take a picture i go absolutely dean so
we took a [__] picture
and he put it on instagram
when i got on the plane that night
i was just checking [__] i checked
instagram
and i saw the picture that he had put up
of him and i and under there was a
little comment
and the guy goes there he is you know
whatever he wrote like a thing about me
there he is the man of steel
there goes a man at a time that wasn't
scared of anything
but today he's scared of everything
and i looked at that comment
whatever
it is what it is some guy and i thought
about it i go you know what
maybe he's right in a way you know i
never had any fear of much and
the watching the news and this [__]
whatever was going on got under my
[__] skin
plus with my vulnerability and that's it
i built up this [__] anxiety maybe
that's what happened but i thought about
it
in a deeper sense you know like
what the [__] is going on with me why
don't i want to do this why don't i want
to do that well yes
i was scared but i also knew one thing
last
year
i moved here in august
and about october my phone started
ringing not a big you know not a big
shock
it just started ringing with little
offers
from movies tv shows it was more tv
shows okay
and
it was like a tv show in north carolina
that and they kept pressing the issue
they really want you to read for it
there was a movie in the dominican
republic that they wanted me to do about
cuba
there was a movie going on
and
somewhere in arizona that reached out to
me like a
a tv show and there was a tv show on abc
that reached out to me in l.a at the
time my head was like you know what man
i i just got here i just [__] got
here
i don't really want to get on a plane
and start traveling all over the [__]
country that's not what i want to do
so that was my mindset but then i spoke
to a dear friend of
the joint podcast i spoke to a dear
friend of the church podcast
great friend of mine greg garcia we were
just chit-chatting and greg told me he
had a show on amazon which i just shot
uh two months ago maybe
and he was telling me that you know
these shows
they require
four hundred thousand dollars per
episode with covet
covert adds an added cost
of four hundred thousand dollars to a tv
show per episode guys
so if you do 10 episodes
of your tv show it's gonna cost you four
million dollars in covert expenses
you're like joey how can that be well
what used to be a van to take me mike my
wife mercy you your wife your kid
to whatever now we can't
eight people can't get in a van
it's gotta be one person for van
if you wanna be
cheap
i was on a job where they put
four people in a [__] man
okay again
this is what i'm saying to you so
i had shot the sopranos
i saw i had heard what it cost them
for those five days we shot just for
covid and i was blown away but let me
give you an example
they put us in a [__] hotel in
midtown manhattan
that was gorgeous they rented the whole
hotel
you couldn't just rent
like eight rooms they had a rent like
the whole hotel
i was basically on a floor
by myself
they had a contractor room
that had a little bit of like it was
outside but really inside what do you
call that like
like yeah like a room that could open up
so air could go in there i mean it was
the end of spring it was the end of fall
it was kind of nice out so they
you know that we could all go in there
nobody would get covered but that was
like i'm saying to you it was me john
maybe mike gandolfini
samson if i say
i think uh
your boy
uh you know
ray liotta there was maybe eight of us
in the whole hotel how many [__]
rooms in the hotel let's say there's six
rooms on the floor
if there's 12 rooms that's 60 [__]
floor 60 rooms
there was eight people in a hotel the
hotel
was catering to us eight
they had two new york city cops
at the front door that's a detail you
got to pay those [__]
they went and got us anything we wanted
to like if we said we need deodorant
they would go to cvs and get us
deodorant they also
had to drive each of us individually
to different rooms and then we had to
get tested and then we were put into
general population after an hour
and even then they didn't want you
mixing and matching you had a covered
[__] lady
they were they're supposed to have three
covet agents
on the job site again this is what i
heard
the many saints in newark had like
[__] eight or nine of them
so i felt safe when i did the many
saints in newark and i saw how they were
doing something how they were doing the
whole covet thing
i felt really safe
so i was like [__] it you know this is
great i had no problems you know
you have to wear a mask the whole time
the only time you don't wear a mask
is after you get tested when they're
about to shoot your scene
and i mean you go into the scene with
your [__] mask on
and some of you later you yell take your
mask off and real quick you got to put
it in your pocket and then you shoot the
scene and she'll say mass back on and
you got to put your mask back on while
you're waiting there so they could
adjust
adjust that [__] light over there and
that flower that's [__] blocking the
camera so now i gotta wait there with my
mask on and then take the [__] mask
off and then shoot the scene again it's
a [__] nightmare but
it keeps everybody safe
you don't want to have a contaminated
set so
once i did the sopranos i was like you
know what
they went [__] deep because you know
david chase is up there in the years
you know director was a little older
whatever
they went all out there was no craft
services
there's no crab services there's no
truck with m m's in it no more that
you'd go and go hmm do you have
marshmallow flavored marshmallows you
know because although the bigger the
movie the more [__] they got peanut m ms
you know they have a bag with no red m
m's in case you're in van halen they got
everything on those big movie sets
so that ended
they give you a thing the night before
and you have to [__]
order your dinner and that's it they
give you a a container with two
meatballs i got spaghetti and meatballs
they gave me two meatballs
pasta and a [__] salad how about you
that's what they give you there's no
more crap service
so what i'm trying to say to you is when
i got all these calls to go to north
carolina
blah blah blah blah blah blah i go why
aren't these guys
shooting in l.a
i know why see when you shoot somewhere
outside of la
it's a little bit more lacks
they said they were going to find places
regions
where the coveted numbers were lower
than you know
usual that's not it
they're shooting in locations
to be out of la
so they have an excuse
that
we didn't know what was going on out
there it's like when they shot
caddyshack and they went to florida and
they [__] walked into a cook party
and then years later they were like we
didn't know what was going on down there
and they didn't
they didn't that's why you shoot in
[__] florida because california is
here and florida's all the way down here
in west palm beach what are the chances
of [__] paramount going back and
forth to [__] florida so
they just left them alone in shooting i
like shooting on location i like when
people call me and say we're shooting
here we're shooting there it's kind of
[__] nice but it makes a guy like me
think
so that i wasn't scared of colvin to say
more i was scared because i know
you're not doing what you're supposed to
be doing and i know you're going to cut
back the producers are so greedy what do
you think they're going to take a pay
cut you know who this is going to affect
the [__] actors
food hotels everything that goes there
they're going to try to [__] you
they're going to try to put mikey and
joey in the same hotel room you guys
hang out together why don't you guys
bunk together it's a great idea no it's
not i don't want to smell a man's fart
and he shouldn't smell my [__] feet
you follow me and then they hit you with
see what you guys don't know at home is
that yeah
they pay you 600 a day to shoot a movie
640 a day you got to pay 10 percent to
your agent it's great [__] money
that's the hollywood you signed up for
that's the hollywood i signed up for
i took a chance and not having a
full-time job but when i do work you're
gonna pay me a little extra
i take that chance in life
that's a decision i make
but when you get to [__] hollywood
you do a couple scale movies and then
they start hitting you by the way ah
this is a sag whatever contract that
means it's not scale it's 456 dollars
okay 450 a day i could live with that
you could all live with that that's a
nice figure
but
then they have
250-day movies
and that's okay you know you're just
getting started and acting who the [__]
are you charleston heston somebody
[__] knows you no you take the 250
you know what i'm saying
then [__] a lot of people don't know
is they have a thing called
low budget
and i got bad news for you guys that
think that you know i have a helicopter
they pay
100 a [__] day
okay and you work all [__] day
they give you overtime after a certain
amount it's a kink [__] deal
and get ready hold on to your seats they
also have an ultra low budget contract
which is 50 a day now i'm sure
you went to acting class and you went to
[__] college for four years to study
drama and to study theater so you could
get out and make 50 a day on a [__]
movie i'm sure when you made the
decision to be a [__] actor that was
included in it how you're gonna make
fifty dollars a [__] day i can make
50 [__] dollars a day pumping gas and
[__] hess down the [__] corner so
50 a [__] day meanwhile that
producer's driving a [__] porsche
and i drove here in my [__] toyota
because my skateboard is getting
serviced you know what i'm saying so
do you understand where i'm going with
this these [__] are gonna take
that 400 000 for covert the first off
they're going to fight to get a deal
they're the cheapest [__] suckers in the
world so they're going to fight to get a
deal they're going to tell you they paid
400 000. that's not what they paid i
don't know if you guys watched that
episode of jre with rogan and bill burr
when they discussed hollywood accounting
nobody remembers that conversation
download that podcast again and take a
look at that listen to that podcast with
joe and bill that called hollywood
accounting
it always goes their way not your way
doesn't go towards the actor's way so
joey what does that ear beating have to
do with alec baldwin think about it
the girl's father who was the [__]
gunsmith whatever there's a name for it
we're not even going to
go there gunsmith whatever the armorer
the armorer girl he was 24 years old her
father's a famous
armorer
they gave her the job she even said she
wasn't skilled enough for the job
she was 24. she didn't feel she even
didn't want the job there's reports
surfacing now
that she didn't want the [__] job
but that's what they do they cut corners
so instead of paying
an armor of five grand what they're
supposed to pay him they take that girl
and they pay her a thousand a day
and she don't know what she's doing the
same one for the guy that was pulling in
the blind the same you know they get a
couple people that they get they're like
the yankees they're not even like the
yankees they're like
they get a couple people that are really
good listen when you shoot a movie
the dp has to be [__] great
i could direct a movie i don't know what
i'm doing
when you see these this movie is
directed by george clooney yeah he's got
a dp you [__] [__]
what's a dp joy director photography
that's the guy that decides on the cuts
the the whole thing then there's another
guy that decides on a budget the
director goes in there to put a hat on
with a [__] fee feed thing like he's
in france he's about to eat an apple and
he's genius but the guy that's really
doing the work is the [__] dp
and the first [__] camera guy and i
don't know all the you know classy names
for him but i've been on 2 000 movies to
let you know that those are the guys
that are doing the work i've worked on a
thousand projects where the guy's the
director you're not the [__] director
they just gave you that title the guy
that's running the show is that guy
behind the [__] camera and that's
what a lot of [__] people don't know
so when you take them and if you looked
at the [__]
thing it's
it said to you
that alec baldwin was a producer on it
and it was a low budget movie
and the reason why
they give you a producer credit on the
low budget movies is so you're attached
to the film it gives you extra money
they can't pay you what you want but if
i make you a producer
you get extra money as a producer you go
in there blind you don't want to know
what mike is making
i don't want to know what joey diaz is
making in my heart i hope you ain't
paying them [__]
because i hope that money is coming to
me
so
when you look at this situation i'm not
happy it happened because the girl holly
the a.d lost her job the dp lost her
life never meant a [__] job
she lost a giant uh her life
joe souza the director of the thing got
shot he spent the day in the hospital
what people are starting to read is that
you guys know there was a walk out on
that movie
that morning
because of unsafe conditions
the gun had gone off three times
two days prior
guys i'm not scared of anything
i just
don't want somebody else to win
the reason why i don't take movies in
north carolina i don't take movies and
[__] anywhere else the only reason i
did that tv show in pittsburgh
was because it was greg garcia and he
was going to take care of me
and i got to be honest he took great
care of me
the production was great but the
production they hired in pittsburgh was
inexperienced
how do i know that because i know what
experienced people [__] do
there was a couple things they did that
experienced people wouldn't do i didn't
say anything i wasn't mad i'm not angry
at it at all it didn't affect me in any
way but i saw that there was a lot of
inexperience
and that's what this is going to call
for you guys don't remember there was
also a horrible [__] spill
on uh
marky wahlberg kevin hart movie
three or four weeks ago the guy died or
he got really bad he fell or something
like this guys
yes it's covered you're gonna see
more of these
you know the world is in a weird place
right now i don't know if you read
what santana said that the world is
vomiting right now the world is not in a
good place right now you know you all
witnessed tom segura go down
or he was about to take a [__] layup
who got he broke 18 [__] bones from a
[__] layup then his wife went down
you know bert had surgery a bunch of
[__] weird things have happened last
night i was walking in the dark and i
didn't see a [__] step and my leg
went straight down if i wouldn't have
kept my foot straight i wouldn't be
talking to you right now i'd be getting
surgery on my [__] ankle i was so
grateful because my leg just dropped
things are gonna happen that don't
usually happen in the real world i mean
yes people get shot on sets the last one
being brandon lee in 1993 or 92 or
whenever the [__] that happened
but this is what happens when you're not
gonna pay everybody
when you're gonna have you know that's
what they do you see they were taking
people out of hotel rooms
people were filing [__]
and this is why i won't take a job out
of state
because i'll take a job in new york you
know why
because if i don't like what i'm saying
i get my call and i come home
i don't [__]
i don't yell
i don't complain
i know what you're gonna pay me up front
it's not gonna be a lot i'm doing this
as a labor of love
but if you're not doing this as a labor
of love
if you're doing this just to be in a
movie you're trying to push this movie
and you're endangering people when you
do a low budget movie you're always
putting people at [__] risk guys
because
you're doing this you could you need
five million
but you're doing this for eight hundred
thousand because you think it's gonna
change your life or you think your story
that you're telling in your stupid
[__] movie is gonna do something for
society it's not and that's why people
are you know how many are [__] those
hundred dollar day movies i've done
let me tell you what
all those halloween all those dog movies
i did for disney they were 100 a day
i did six of them
i did boiler room i did if you look at
my mdb
there's got to be 1500 a day movies you
know what happens now
when you call me for 100 a day movie and
it's i'm not gonna lie to you guys
it started in 2013.
i did not have a [__] acting career i
was doing all these from 2007 that's all
that came out after the strike was
hundred dollar a day movies hey listen i
put my pants on one leg at a time i like
to act i like to practice my craft if
it's a great project if you come to me
with a great project you're not gonna
wear me the [__] out i'm not gonna have
to be there
25 [__] hours a day for your
stupidity if you guarantee me that i'll
do your low budget project you're gonna
get me out of there in five or six days
i'll do it for you but i swear to god
since 2013
i made a decision one day in like 2012 i
said
i'm not doing low run no low budget
movies no more they give you 100 a day i
got to bring my own suit
they give you 100 after taxes is 72
whatever it is 78 dollars and you still
got to give your agent 10 commission
that puts me at [__] 68
the dry cleaning for the suit that's
another 20. by the end of the [__]
day you don't make a dime of course you
did it as a labor of love but you got to
take care of me the movie boilermaker
i'm talking about i went in there one
day
three days in a row
i'm in there they got like cheese whips
you know the cheese crackers with the
cheese in the middle
the peanut butter in the middle they had
like that and m m's
but i'm looking at these [__]
producers and then they did something
that i never had heard of
i'm like what's for lunch and they're
like when i have lunch
they go but you're allowed to leave for
an
hour i was like what are you talking
about
what the [__] are you talking the last
thing you wanted your actors to leave
because what if they get in the car
accident
what if they get sideswiped not that
they're going to get hurt
but you don't want them out you want
them to relax bring them their food
let them relax let them get their wits
to them after three days then they made
me work on a sunday when i got there on
a [__] sunday again the table was
empty i went in my wallet i had done the
thing called the i don't know some
project about a pizza place again that
was the same way the first night i got
there all night shoot
there was a piece of bread on the
[__] table that's it with peanut
butter and they brought from home you
could tell the kids had [__] stuck
their fingers in there and [__]
the next night there was a guy there
from after the place looked at the taj
mahal they had peaches and cranberry
juice and all this [__]
and i was talking to the guy and i go
this wasn't like this last night he goes
what are you talking about i wasn't like
this there was nothing here i worked 10
hours there was nothing to eat
he gave me his car he goes i work for
after that's why i'm here whenever you
do these movies if they don't have
the [__] [__] on here call me and
i'll come and shut them down i'm like
what
so when i got on boilermaker that sunday
sunday now again
when you make me work on a sunday on a
low budget movie that means i'm doing it
for your
for your [__] passion it's not for
mine so do me a favor if there's
supposed to be food here
have food but go the extra mile stop and
get some bagels for the cast what's it
gonna cost you
30 bucks
to make everybody happy to show them
you're on their side on the lord's day
no they had nothing
not a donut not a [__] cockroach they
had nothing
i went off i'm like you [__]
got an hour before i called after
they looked at me like what do you mean
you're gonna call after i go listen i'm
not a crime stopper but i'm about to
join the ranks because i pay [__]
union dues i pay union dues like a
[__] i pay union dues every
quarter and then yearly they bang out
for one and a half points of what you
made all year not to mention the 10
points you guys you guys have no [__]
idea
so when you guys are sitting there going
how could this happen that alec baldwin
listen i feel bad for alec baldwin he's
about to get a dose of [__] reality
inserted in his life he took a life
that's a dose of [__] reality
he doesn't deserve to go to jail he
didn't do anything wrong
somebody gave him a gun told him it was
clean
now we have to find out why he was
pointing it at her why was pointing at
him and that's a complete different
story but why that happened is because
why i'm telling you is because why i'm
sitting my ass at home minding my
[__] business
people are cutting corners they're
charging you all the dough in the world
whether you go to a hotel go to a hotel
go on vacation
and go on their website they got all the
amenities shoeshine
24-hour valet where do you get there
oh the pool is closed because of covert
we don't have a bartender
because the covet
the valets
because the covet we don't have oatmeal
in the morning because of kobe we don't
have a [__] breakfast anymore you
come down and get an apple like a
prisoner and a [__] and a [__] old
[__] shoprite bagel one of those
[__] bagels you know they don't even
give you that at the hotel room this is
happening across the board guys so
before you go on your [__] vacation
you know when you do these concerts
they're charging you more than ever do
they have special filters for your
[__] covert breathing [__] no
they're just telling you that it's like
the airline people when they started
charging you for luggage for the price
of [__] oil once oil went down that
they give you that hundred dollar back
or that 25 back [__] no that's the same
thing they're doing on movies and tv
productions that's why i'm and then look
at
let's let's talk about it they're
starting to say this [__]
they call it you know what these
gentiles call it is the word is toxic
well let me tell you something
anytime you have a star
in those movies it's toxic
why because they make a demand
if they make one demand
already you're going to have a toxic
environment why
because let's say i call the producer
and go
you want joe diaz
joe diaz doesn't work
nights
now this motherfucker's got to go okay
i got to do early [__] mornings
because joey diaz doesn't work nights
so now i gotta go to mike who's the [__]
and mike loves to stay up late at night
and draw pictures of superheroes [__]
monkeys in the ass
now mike has to get up at six in the
[__] morning for this
mike's got two kids
mike takes his kids to school in the
morning he's used to
but because joey diaz wants to be there
at six
mike loses all this now mike has to even
get his cousin who he [__] hates to
come over in the morning and put the
kids on the bus and give him fifty
dollars a day out of his pocket
so how do you think mike feels about joe
diaz already
when he comes to the eye and he goes
listen i
you're [__] up i can't do it well
this is the job either you take it you
know joe diaz
doesn't want to work nights
so already mike is going into that job
kind of not liking joe diaz even though
he's never met joe diaz
he's joe diaz is costing mike [__]
money already
so now he doesn't like joe diaz but two
things could happen
joe diaz could come in he's a great guy
takes care of mike you know [__] around
with them they talk about music
mike overlooks it or i could come in and
be a dick
and now mike is going to tell
the rest of the people what's going on
with him
and how i affected his [__] life and
that's going to cause a riff on the set
that that's how just by him saying
he doesn't want to work nights
that's how quick a toxic person is i was
reading
something out there by holly berry i'm
sure you guys wrote that she was doing a
movie
and the guy said something to where the
guy was eating pain pills he would
disappear and eat pain pills the
director and she called them out she
asked them to get help they did an
intervention on the scent and the guy
was addicted to her and holly berry just
said i'm getting my black ass out of
here
and she was describing a toxic [__]
work set
listen every [__] worksheet
set i've been on has been toxic
except the longest yard wasn't toxic
many saints in newark wasn't toxic
taxi wasn't toxic i was only there three
days you know
spider-man had no
nobody was toxic on that i mean whatever
mcguire took him a little while to get
out of the [__]
out of the [__] thing because he was
playing those stupid
nintendo games or whatever he wouldn't
they would like where's where's maguire
i don't know he's and they would yell
toby come on here they would go hold on
i almost reached the sixth universe
whatever the [__]
they're going for in those [__]
stupid games or whatever
but that's you know i've never really
worked
i've worked on maybe i'm not gonna lie
to you i've worked on maybe 20 of those
toxic sets and they suck and you know
what those toxic sets
i've always gone off on
you know
toxic sets all those halloween all those
dog movies i did
those sets were [__] toxic why
because they were low budget
the producer was one of the stars of the
movie
and he was a [__] dick and yeah
they're just dicks these guys are
[__] dicks so
that's what makes a set toxic is when
you have
[__] dicks another movie i did
whatever with uh the movie i did about
that [__] dude who who lived in a
hotel who in las vegas who was a pilot
and [__] it didn't get much traction
that set was [__] toxic and alec
baldwin was in that movie
in fact my scene was alex baldwin they
probably cut it but he was he's just a
toxic [__] dude i'm not blaming alex
for the shooting
i'm not saying he should go to jail you
know we should go to jail the [__]
producers the production company
somebody's got an answer for that girl
obviously there was problems on that set
people were dying to walk off that
[__] set
so
my heart goes out to alec baldwin for
what he's going through as
as far as what's going through his head
you know when you're a [__] dick
full-time and something like that
happens that's what you need to [__]
wake you up now this would never happen
if this was a regular world you know uh
three people that you're getting high
with
and they just drop on the floor that
doesn't happen in the regular [__]
world how do i know i did coke for 29
years i did coke with a lot of [__]
people in the [__] room and never did
i wake up and there was three [__]
people dead that happens in this [__]
pandemic because the world is on his
[__] axles all these little stupid
things that you see don't let them
affect you it's just what happens
in a covered [__] world that's it
it's just bad luck that's why i don't
take any chances if you're on a ladder
don't reach for the plant
because you might fall the [__] off that
lad it's like i told you [__] i
was at the gym one day and i went to
[__] pick up like a ball with 190
pounds i was just about to pick it up
and i saw that video of [__]
sagura hitting the floor and i go this
is the chances you don't need to take
like i said to you [__] there's
a movie something that interests me i'll
go do it but i'm very [__] cautious
i'm very cautious of things i just i
didn't want you guys to think that i was
being like [__] scared
or prima donna i just don't want to do
them because
why would i want to do somebody else's
[__] dream for half the money
what if i go to north carolina and
somebody hits me with a dose of bad
breath and it's got covered in it and
now i got to sit in the hotel room for
two weeks out of my pocket
because they're not going to pay for me
for getting covered and to stay in that
hotel room and i gotta [__] i can't
see my family what good am i doing for
100 hours a day for four [__] days
i'd rather deliver chinese food that
szechuan i could just call her up and go
lily i want to deliver four days and i
gotta pick up a hundred dollars
this is what i'm saying to you guys that
you have to
pick and choose
carefully right now i'm sure you're
dying to go on a vacation to some
[__] bar i can't wait
till they lift the sanctions that i can
go
listen if you go over there what you
know who the [__] knows what's going on
over there
yeah i'll get back on stage in new
jersey i'll keep it light no second
shows
but for right now i'm not getting on no
plan and going nowhere there ain't
nowhere i want to go i don't want to get
stuck anywhere
i don't want to get hurt like i told you
guys when i started this thing i'm not
going anywhere for a while i went to
california because i had to and it was a
one-day [__] trip and i went to
pennsylvania for three days to shoot a
[__] show
that's it i don't need to go anywhere i
don't want what i don't want some guy
pointing a [__] bb gun at me and also
i'm missing an eye i don't need that
[__] in my [__] world and that's what
happens man on those [__] movies so
if you're an actor and you get called
for those [__] movies
if you need the money i understand it
but you don't need a hundred dollars for
a [__] movie not they they don't need
to pay you that that's that's a faux pas
of that [__] union you know i'm happy
to be part of screen actors guild but
they got to be looking at the screen
actors guild a little bit more closely
also
it's time for people to open up their
[__] eyes you know on these [__]
sets you know and that's why i told
producers now when they call me for [__]
some guy just called me a few weeks ago
he's like hey i want to offer you this
thing like okay
he goes can you tell me your agent's
name and i told him he's like
you know when you talk to those people
they want a lot of money
i deserve a lot of [__] money you
know why why would i want them to get me
money
i know what you guys are trying to do
you're trying to pay me [__] scale or
on the [__] scale for me to go there
and chase other italian people and
talk say some crazy [__] you got to pay
now you got to pay during this pandemic
i don't want to be on tv i'm not a
[__] young kid anymore i don't need
to be on [__] tv i need a job i need
a career i would love to be on on law
and order full-time and why do you think
i'm reaching for law and order because i
know
law and orders got too much to lose
they're not they're going to treat their
sex right they're going to test they're
going to keep us separated they're going
to put us in nice hotels they're going
to hire an armorer that's [__] you
know the real armor or the hire
you know something you know or don't you
first off you don't need to [__] pull
a trigger no more
okay all you need to do is point a gun
at people and with cgi whatever the [__]
you call it they put smoke and they put
bang
that's it that that that's how i don't
know why they were
bullets or bl
but that's how cheap they were being
people that's how cheap they were
[__] being so i hope that the family
of this i i
i wish light and love to the family who
lost the dp i forget what her name is
i'm [__] so sorry
i should have wrote it the [__] down
um
my heart goes out to the people on that
set that witnessed that
but uh if you're an actor or whatever
the [__] you are cover your ass when i
want if you do take a job ask questions
[__] you you're the [__] right now
they need people to work you're not like
going to be a [__] like they're going
to hire you for dick wages and treat you
like [__] that that [__] [__] sales
if you go for a job now they need you
more than ever they're hiring
inexperienced people they're hiring
people that shouldn't even be in the
[__] room for these jobs so
what am i saying i'm saying that this is
your chance when you take a job ask
questions and if you don't feel
comfortable with something don't [__]
do it and tell them i'm not [__]
doing it they're going to have to hire
you because what are their [__]
options you got them by the [__]
skinnies you got them by the ball hands
now who gives the [__] what they think
i know with me when you call me for a
movie or something now
i ask a thousand questions and the doe
rate me better be right or it's not
worth it for me to risk
my family to bring covert back into my
[__] house go [__] yourself what was
her name
elena hutchinson and she was really
[__] good as a dp i read a lot of
good stuff about it even afi is doing a
scholarship
after her name you know
listen man
this [__] happens but it could be
[__] avoidable and like i said with
mike before
why did you have a gun on the set with
blanks
you could do that in post production you
could do that on his phone this is what
i'm saying to you guys this is the you
know
and this is why i'm not doing [__] it
wasn't because i was a [__] or i was
scared i'm not risking
what i'm doing for somebody else's
[__]
passion so they could go yeah thank you
oh you were great get them out of the
[__] room then you call them a week
later for a piece of your reel they
don't return your calls i this ain't my
first rodeo [__]
thank you very much
for uh watching the joint today it was
uh great here
to talk to you guys it was great to talk
to you about better help and how it's
helped me and
great to talk about people [__]
cutting corners i can't stand these
[__] but that's what you're
gonna do so if you call me for an acting
job a comedy job or whatever
i'm gonna ask you a thousand questions
covered questions the audience you're
gonna go to me i can't do business with
this guy because he gives a [__] i do
give a [__] so
i'm sorry charlie the best tasting tuna
gets to be scott starkist [__]
don't forget
laughing gas
partnered up with packwoods we're back
[__] living high on the [__]
hog
and thank you for watching another
fun-filled this is the last monday of
october what the [__]
the year is going [__] flat fast the
next time you see my cuban ass will be
wednesday but the next time you see my
cuban ass after that or be all saints
day all souls day all souls day is
november 1st i'm looking forward to
[__] november
that's it it was a fun-filled [__]
month
have a great [__] couple days
i'll see you [__] wednesday
morning
tip top magoo
ready to go and now
for word for my [__] sponsor
jack
all right you bad [__] i had a
good time with you today
[__] people shooting movies and not
[__] want to pay you [__] suckers
anyway the joint is brought to you by
better help
betterhelp.com
diaz is the best it's online therapy the
best way to think about therapy is like
this you get all changes for your cause
you want to to prevent bigger issues
down the road therapy is the same thing
only for your brain
going to therapy is routine maintenance
for your mental and emotional wellness
you prevent bigger issues down the road
you avoid
going into hell i mean guys you guys
know from listening to the podcast
i was in hell if you have any doubts
just put on the first three months of
podcast i couldn't even have words come
to my mouth and after the surgery i was
really down i didn't know who to talk to
better help was there i signed up it
took me five minutes they referred me to
a girl named dana a woman named dana who
helped me through the initial steps of
getting out of this fear and
the you know just what i was going
through guys i didn't know what i wanted
to do
and i had questions and i had been
running it through my friends and
sometimes you just need a professional
better help there's customized online
therapy they offer video phone and live
chat sessions if you don't want to see
anyone on camera you don't have to it's
much more affordable than in person
therapy and you can start communicating
with your therapist in less than 48
hours why invest in anything else when
you can invest in your mind
now just for the joint listeners what
i'm going to do is i'm going to give you
10 off
your first month that's four visits
to let you know if this is gonna work
for you and it will
betterhelp.com
d i a z again that's betterhelp.com
slash diaz you can email them they'll
email you back they're always there for
you and you can schedule and cancel
there's no hassles right there on the
computer go to betterhelp.com
slash diaz and get your therapeutic mind
started you need help this has been
really heavy on a lot of people i never
thought
i would be man enough to go for help
but the pandemic kicked my ass too so
better help was there for me so if i was
you
betterhelp.com slash diaz get 10 percent
off your first month
now that your mind is right it's time to
sling some dick the joint is also
brought to you by blue chew blue chew is
here to make your dick [__] scary for
halloween that's what you want you want
your dick to scare people you know what
i'm saying like i went over the [__]
mikey's house he [__] me for eight
hours straight smoke was coming out of
my monkey that's
the goal blue chew is an online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis and a
fraction of the course you could take at
any time day and night you could wake up
in the morning pop one of these and put
mama to work and [__] for breakfast you
sign up at bluetooth.com
and talk to one of our licensed medical
providers
once you're approved you receive your
prescription within days
the best part is it's all online you
don't got to leave the house
no doctor's visit no pharmacy no
judgment
no no fat chick behind the counter at
cvs
eyeballing you to death with your brand
new dick
you know this ships right to your door
in a discreet package
not even your mailman knows what's going
on bluetooth tablets are made in the u.s
of a
you're going to give them that american
old school [__] and [__] you know what
i'm saying way cheaper than a pharmacy
and it's reliable and it's [__]
tremendous
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence before you sling that holiday
dick
it's time to perform [__] and blue
chew is gonna help you they got a
special deal for you you try blue chew
for free with promo code joey that's how
i'm showing up monday with dick pills
for free on a monday they just cost you
five dollars for shipping who's better
than your uncle joey
nobody if you order today you'll have
them by [__] thursday or friday
halloween oh my god a [__] costume
will be on fire and you have to [__]
dose her off with the sperm of love
that's blue chew promo code joey to
receive your first month free and as
also and as always i want to thank
bluechu for sponsoring the joint
the next one i love with all my heart
tremendous
the best supplements on the market
period on it
oh and nit tremendous
i was always a fan on it but after i
moved to jersey i really hyped it up a
little bit with the new mood
the shroom tech but then they came out
with the alpha brain black label
about two months ago and it was exactly
what
the doctor ordered
i take my
pill every morning and i'm firing on all
[__] levels you understand me i feel
better i feel energized my mind feels
energized i don't feel confused anymore
the fog has been lifted thanks
to alpha brain
black label go to on it.com right now
look at the great selection of products
that they have whether it's the alpha
brain
the new mood
the shroom tech sport the mct i can hook
you up with supplements i can't do
anything for you with the iron
kettlebells club bats but anything on
this supplement i'll get you 10 off
listen the reason why i've been on it so
long as they stand behind that product
alpha brain if you don't like it if it
doesn't work for you
you call them up they'll send you your
money back and they don't even want the
product when somebody does that i know
that they believe in that product and
that's the people i want to do business
with
so go to honor.com right now look at the
fine selection
of supplements order something think of
your uncle joey we're getting stronger
they got tremendous protein powder they
got a tremendous protein bar the peanut
butter are great
they got chips i mean
honor is tremendous but it starts with
you going to that page right now
ordering some alpha brain and get your
mind right for the [__] holidays in
the new year [__] you want to have
a great november start it with alpha
brain go to on it press in joey
and get 10 off delivered to your house i
want to thank honett.com i want to thank
bluetooth.com and i want to thank
betterhelp.com for sponsoring the joint
but i want to thank you [__] savages
for always having my back have a great
week have a great monday stay black and
i'll see you [__]
wednesday tip top [__] magoo i
love you
[Music]
you